قالت الاستخبارات الداخليه الالمانيه ان
مجموعه مواطنون الرايخ كانت في طريقها
لتنفيذ عمل على قدر عالم من الخطوره قبل
ان توجه لها ضربه قويه اذ كانت تحت
المراقبه منذ ربيع العام الحالي ووضعت
الاستخبارات الالمانيه ان لدى المجموعات
رساله اسلحه غير مشروعه اغلبها من مخزونات
الجيش الالماني واضافت الاستخبارات انه لا
يزال هناك ما يكفي من الاسلحه في حوزه
تنظيم مواطن الرايخ وان بعض معتقلين جاءوا
من الجيش الالماني واشارت الى ان مواطن
رائع يضم واحدا و20 الف عضو يؤمنون
بافكاره
هذا وقال رئيس الجهاز الاستخبارات
الداخليه الالمانيه توماس هادم بانك ان
بلاده وجهت ضربه قويه لتنظيم مواطن الرايخ
واضاف في مقابله مع قناه زد دي اف
الالمانيه ان المجموعه ارتكبت اكثر من
1000 جريمه العام الماضي
يبلغ عدد اتباعها 21000 شخص ارتكبت هذه
المجموعه اكثر من 1000 جريمه العام الماضي
ونحن نراقبها منذ ربيع هذا العام وانا
اعرف مخططاتها مجموعه مواطنين رايح مغامره
بالاسلحه والعديد من افرادها يمتلكنا
قانونيه او غير قانونيه ومن مخزونات الجيش
الالماني بعض المعتقلين جاءوا من صفوف
القوات المسلحه الالمانيه ولديهم المهارات
المناسبه من خلال خدمتهم في الوحدات
الخاصه العسكريه
الالمانيه اعلنت اعتقال 25 شخصا بينهم
جنود سابقون ينتمون الى جماعه من اقصى
اليمين بتهمه الاعداد لاسقاط الدوله وقالت
الحكومه ان المجموعه كانت تنوي الاستيلاء
على السلطه بالقوه وانشاء جيش موازن
وتنفيذها هجمات داخل
لالمانيا
ينضم الينا من امام البرلمان الالماني
البونستان في برلين مراسل الجزيره عيسى
طيبي اهلا بك عيسى اذا مزيد من المعلومات
يتم الكشف عنها الى اي درجه تثير هذه
المعلومات القلق في المانيا لا
حقيقه الرئيس الالماني
قال بانه لم نتوقع ان يصل التهديد الى هذه
الخطوره هذا التصريح اليوم من الرئيس
الالماني جاء اتباعا لتصريح حساسه الذي
نعتبره انفسهم بانهم في مواجهه من يريدون
القضاء على الدوله واسقاطها بقوه السلاح
هذا امر تراه الدوله ويتراه هرم السلطه
هنا في المانيا بانها نجحوا في في مهاجمته
في عقر داره هذه النقطه النقطه الثانيه
كده النائب العمل في جرالي من توضيح جديد
بان الاعتقالات قد تصل الى افراد جدد وقد
يتم توسيعها هذا امر معطاء جديد ايضا تحدث
بان القاضيه في محكمه برلين الابتدائيه
والقياديه في حزب البديل وعضوه البرلمان
الالماني سابقه سيد بريجيت بكمال كانت
كانت
تعطى لها حقيبه العدل في حكومه المتامرين
كما وصفها ويقصد بها حكومه تنظيم الرايخ
التي كشف النقاب عنها وبان المجلس الذي
يتزعمه سيد هنرش الثالث عشر هو ايضا رجل
شكل جسم حكوميا من وزارات وقام
بمحاولات مفاوضات واتصالات مع روسيا
النقطه الاخرى العسكريه في التنظيم التي
كشفت عنها برلين اليوم هي مخزون الاسلحه
تحدثت عن مخزون النوعي من هذه من الاسلحه
هذا التنظيم وبان جزء من الاسلحه بين يدي
التنظيم حسب التقارير الاستخباراتيه هي
قادمه من مخزونات الجيش الالماني التي
كانت تعطى لاكرانيا النقطه الاخرى ايضا في
المقاتلين او المسلحين داخل التنظيم تحدث
اليوم رئيس جهاز الاستخبارات الالمانيه
داخليه بانهم قادمون من الوحدات الخاصه
ويمتلكون مهارات المتقدمه نعم شكرا جزيلا
لك عيسى اعطيني مراسل الجزيره من امام